I'm Darby Harper just watch me are you
sitting down for this I see dead people
I help them pass on to the next World
you'd think that'd be my life's biggest
burden but it is a distant second to
where I'm forced to spend my days
high school that's Capri Donahue head
cheerleader it's a cheer just for
shallow hot girls I'm so glad you asked
and the answer is that's offensive
Capri knows I'm the one person she can't
get to like her Darby I thought you went
here
Capri give me my clothes why would I
take her clothes so planning on
attending a funeral she can be a little
sometimes extra psychotic
I'm reporting live
Frederick Douglass High School where
yesterday students witnessed the
shocking death of head cheerleader
Caffrey Donahue
what's up wake up [ __ ] oh God damn it
you can't see me what are you doing here
my sweet 17 is coming up in a month all
I want is this party help me then I'll
move on in what world do you think I can
throw your dream party in a world where
I make you popular enough to do it
who is that I want her but
any press is good press
sing a dead person
he is a very traumatic experience you
look like you've just seen a ghost
this is Criminal bullying
I think it's criminally good haunting
[Music]